dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly Shana affair
now that facial recognition is becoming
more and more of a hot topic let's talk
a bit about 3d face reconstruction this
is a problem where we have a 2d input
photograph or a video of a person and
the goal is to create a piece of 3d
geometry from it to accomplish this
previous works often required
combination of proper alignment of the
face multiple photographs and dense
correspondences which is a fancy name
for additional data that identifies the
same regions across these photographs
but this new formulation is the holy
grail of all possible versions of this
problem because it requires nothing else
but one 2d photograph the weapon of
choice for this work was a convolutional
neural network and the data set the
algorithm was trained on couldn't be
simpler it was given a large database of
2d input image and 3d output geometry
pairs this means that the neural network
can look at a lot of these pairs and
learn how these input photographs are
mapped to 3d geometry and as you can see
the results are absolutely insane
especially given the fact that it works
for arbitrary face positions and many
different expressions and even with
occlusions however this is not your
classical convolutional neural network
because as we mentioned the input is 2d
and the output is 3d so the question
immediately arises what kind of data
structure should be used for the output
the authors went for a 3d voxel array
which is essentially a cube in which we
build up the face from small identical
LEGO pieces this representation is
similar to the terrain in the game
Minecraft only the resolution of these
blocks is finer the process of guessing
how these voxel arrays should look based
on the input photograph is referred to
in the research community as volumetric
regression this is what this work is
about and now comes the best part an
online demo is also available where we
can either try some prepared images or
we can also upload our own so while I
ran my own experiments don't leave me
out of the good stuff and make sure you
post your results in the comment section
the
source code is also available for you
fellow tinker's out there the
limitations of this technique includes
the inability of detecting expressions
that are very far away from the ones
seen in the training set and as you can
see in the videos temporal coherence
could also use some help this means that
if we have video input the
reconstruction has some tiny differences
in each frame maybe a recurrent neural
network like some variant of long
short-term memory could address this in
the near future
however those are trickier and more
resource intensive to train properly
very excited to see how these solutions
evolve and of course two minute papers
is going to be here for you to talk
about some amazing upcoming works thanks
for watching and for your generous
support and I'll see you next time
[Music]
you